No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet. So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks Copilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs to help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar slice work.
没人会为了汉克的电子表格而去他的店里，他们是为了那份美味的披萨。然而最近，店里却冷清了下来。于是汉克决定重新推出1美元一片的披萨。他请微软Excel中的Copilot查看他的销售额和成本，以帮助他判断自己是否负担得起。Copilot向汉克展示了资金的去向，以及哪些小细节能让1美元披萨的方案行得通。
Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365Copilot.com slash work. Many boys form deep friendships in childhood, but as they become teens, something changes. They become more reluctant to open up to others and report fewer close, rich friendships. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who has spent decades studying boys' friendships and emotional development about why that happens and what it means for boys and men and for everyone
现在，汉克的店门口排起了长队。汉克负责做披萨，Copilot负责处理电子表格。欲了解更多信息，请访问M365Copilot.com/work。许多男孩在童年时期会建立深厚的友谊，但随着他们进入青春期，情况发生了变化。他们变得更不愿意向他人敞开心扉，报告的亲密、丰富的友谊也减少了。今天，我们将采访一位研究男孩友谊和情感发展数十年的心理学家，探讨这种现象发生的原因，以及它对男孩、男人乃至所有人意味着什么。
else. What do boys learn about masculinity through their childhood and teen years? How do those lessons affect their mental health? and relationships as they grow up, how do the norms and ideals of boy culture affect women and girls as well, and what can parents and educators do to help us all stay emotionally connected to ourselves and each other? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Niobie Way, a professor of developmental psychology and director of the Science of Human Connection Lab at New York University. Her work focuses on how
此外，男孩在童年和青少年时期学到了关于男子气概的什么？这些教训如何影响他们成年后的心理健康和人际关系？男孩文化的规范和理想又是如何影响女性和女孩的？父母和教育工作者能做些什么来帮助我们所有人保持与自己和他人的情感联系？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是纽约大学发展心理学教授、人类联系科学实验室主任尼奥比·韦博士。她的工作重点是
culture shapes child development, especially in boys and young men, and how to foster connection and combat loneliness. She's the author of more than 100 academic articles and books. Her newest book is Rebels with a Cause, Reimagining Boys, Ourselves, and Our Culture. Her previous book, Deep Secrets, boys' Boys' friendships and the Crisis of Connection, was the inspiration for the Oscar-nominated movie, close. Dr. Way, thank you for joining me today. Oh, I'm so delighted to be here and thank you for the invitation. In your latest book and in your research, you talk about boy culture. What do you mean by that term? What is boy culture? Well, this is an interesting thing. So boy culture, and I want to make a very clear to your listeners that boy is in quotation, not boy culture, meaning it's a stereotype
文化如何塑造儿童发展，尤其是男孩和年轻男性的发展，以及如何促进联系和对抗孤独。她是100多篇学术文章和书籍的作者。她的最新著作是《叛逆者有因：重构男孩、我们自己和我们的文化》。她之前的著作《深层秘密：男孩的友谊与联系危机》是奥斯卡提名电影《亲密》的灵感来源。韦博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。哦，我很高兴能来到这里，谢谢您的邀请。在您的最新著作和研究中，您谈到了“男孩文化”。您所说的这个词是什么意思？什么是男孩文化？嗯，这是一件有趣的事情。关于“男孩文化”，我想向听众明确一点，这里的“男孩”是加了引号的，不是指真正的男孩文化，而是指一种刻板印象。
of a boy. It's not a real boy. And the important part of this is what I'm about to say is it's taught to us by real boys. So real boys tell us how we've stereotyped boys in a way that's not only damaging them, but in some cases killing them. And so I want to be very dramatic about it because the results are very dramatic. And so boy culture is essentially a culture that aligns with a stereotype of a boy that only values their hard side. So only wants autonomy, doesn't care about connection only wants to be stoic, doesn't care about their own vulnerabilities, doesn't even have the capacity to be vulnerable, that doesn't have the soft skills that so-called girls and women have. They just have their hard skills and in fact, their softsills, they're sort of, you
它不是一个真实的男孩。最重要的一点是，我接下来要说的是，这是由真实的男孩教给我们的。真实的男孩告诉我们，我们是如何以一种不仅伤害他们，甚至在某些情况下杀死他们的方式来刻板化男孩的。我想对此表达得戏剧化一些，因为结果确实非常戏剧化。所以，男孩文化本质上是一种符合男孩刻板印象的文化，它只重视他们的“硬”的一面。它只想要自主权，不关心联系；只想要坚忍，不关心自己的脆弱，甚至没有能力变得脆弱；它没有所谓的女孩和女性所拥有的“软技能”。他们只有“硬技能”，事实上，他们的“软技能”被认为
know, emotionally and relationally unintelligent compared to girls and women. That's all part of a stereotype of a boy that according to my almost 40 years of research with young people, and it's been all gender identities, but the point is that the boys and young men are telling story we're not listening to. What we learn from them is they not only have that intelligence, they have that intelligence as much as all other humans. And the fact that we've stereotyped them as not being emotionally and relationally intelligent and not wanting emotionally intimate friendships is what's damaging them, what's leading them to suicide and homicide and mass violence. And by the way, I just want to finally end with your response, the response. You learn that not only
与女孩和女性相比，他们在情感和关系上是不聪明的。这都是男孩刻板印象的一部分。根据我近40年来对年轻人的研究，涵盖了所有性别认同，重点是男孩和年轻男性正在讲述一个我们没有在倾听的故事。我们从他们身上学到的是，他们不仅拥有那种智慧，而且他们拥有那种智慧的程度与所有其他人一样。我们把他们刻板印象化为在情感和关系上不聪明、不想要情感亲密的友谊，这正是伤害他们、导致他们自杀、他杀和大规模暴力的原因。顺便说一句，我最后想用你的回应来结束，这个回应。你不仅从我的研究中的男孩和年轻男性那里学到了这一点，
from boys in my research, boys and young men in my research, you learn it from the manifestos of mass shooters. So they say the exact same thing. They're just more isolated kids. So they end up committing violence. But the point is it's the same story. And they've been telling this story to me since 1987 when I began to do research on social emotional development at Harvard as a grad student. So what happens to boys' friendships as they move from childhood to adolescents? Why do the ties seem to weaken them? And then what are the consequences for boys and young men? Kim, I love your questions. Thank you. They're really getting into. You clearly read my book. And it's beautiful to be asked these questions. So this is what happens. And I report this in deep secrets,
你还可以从大规模枪击案凶手的宣言中了解到这一点。他们说的是完全一样的事情。他们只是更孤立的孩子。所以他们最终实施了暴力。但重点是，这是同一个故事。自1987年我作为研究生在哈佛大学开始研究社会情感发展以来，他们就一直向我讲述这个故事。那么，当男孩从童年进入青春期时，他们的友谊发生了什么变化？为什么这些联系似乎减弱了？这对男孩和年轻男性有什么后果？金，我喜欢你的问题。谢谢。它们真的切中了要害。你显然读过我的书。被问到这些问题真是太好了。这就是发生的事情。我在《深层秘密》中报告了这一点，
my previous book that was written about 13 years ago. What happens is, and boys again, everything I say I learned from listening to boys and young men. So it's not my theory. It's not my, you know, it's my finding, but it's directly from the mouths of boys. What happens as of my developmental psychologist, and for all the listeners, they know exactly what that is, which is unusual for my audience, which is I follow the same kids over time. So I follow, you know, our teams have been following young people from the ages of 11, 12 to when, you know, following them all throughout 18 and 19. So early, middle and late adolescence. And what we hear, that's the developmental work, and I say this to all you wonderful APA members that get it, it's the
这是我大约13年前写的前一本书。发生的事情是——再次强调，我所说的一切都是通过倾听男孩和年轻男性的声音学到的。所以这不是我的理论。这不是我的，你知道，这是我的发现，但它直接来自男孩的口中。作为一名发展心理学家，对于所有听众来说，他们确切地知道这意味着什么，这在我的听众中是不寻常的，那就是我长期跟踪同一群孩子。所以，你知道，我们的团队一直在跟踪从11、12岁到18、19岁的年轻人。所以是青春期早期、中期和晚期。我们听到的是——这就是发展工作，我向所有理解这一点的优秀APA成员说——是发展工作讲述了关于男孩文化影响的故事，我会告诉你原因。因为在11、12和13岁时，男孩的谈话方式和所有其他人一样。他们谈话的方式像女孩，但其实并不完全像女孩。这只是像一个人类。他们谈论对友谊的渴望。他们谈论对联系的渴望。他们会说，如果我没有他，他，我会感到非常孤独。我会想自杀。他们直接将其与心理健康联系起来，将他们的友谊直接与心理健康联系起来。他们揭示了他们的——每次谈到这个我都会起鸡皮疙瘩。这太美了。他们揭示了他们的关系智慧，即观察人类世界并理解
developmental work that tells the story about the impact of boy culture, and I'll tell you why. Because at 11, 12, and 13, boys are talking like all other humans. They're talking like girls, but it's not really like girls. It's just like a human. They talk about their desire for friendships. They talk about their desire for connection. They say things if I wasn't, if they have close friendships, they say if I didn't have him, him, I would feel all alone. I'd want to kill myself. They link it directly to mental health, their friendships directly to mental health. They reveal their, and this gives me the chills every time I talk about it. It's so beautiful. They reveal their relational intelligence, the capacity to look at the human world and understand
在愤怒之下总是隐藏着受伤的感情。他们直接这样说。你知道，我可能对你很生气，但实际上是因为我觉得你轻视了我，这伤害了我的感情。你知道，他们懂。他们拥有这种非凡的关系智慧，能够理解人类世界、矛盾以及我们伪装情绪的方式等等，试图去，你知道，他们不明白为什么我们会要求他们做除了做一个人之外的任何事情。然后，随着他们长大，以及“像个男人”的压力——这对心理学家来说是关键的一点，不仅是“像个男人”，而且要成熟，金，要成为一个成年人——我们要求他们基本上把他们的软技能，他们所谓的软需求——这不是一种性别认同，
that underneath anger has always hurt feelings. They say that directly. You know, I may be pissed at you, but it's really that I feel like you dissed me and it hurts my feelings. You know, they get it. They have this extraordinary relational intelligence of getting the human world and the contradictions and the way we fake emotions and all those kinds of things to try to, you know, and they don't understand why we would ask them to do anything else but be a human. And then as they get older and the pressures to man up, and this is the critical thing for psychologists, not only to man up, but to mature Kim, to become a grown up, we ask them to basically take their soft skills, their soft, so-called soft needs. It's not a gender identity.
这是一种人类需求，但我们将其性别化为女性化，所以。我们告诉他们要把这些隐藏起来。事实上，这些技能并不重要，也不是我们真正重视的东西。我可以告诉你为什么我们，我知道这一点，因为我们重视认知智能。我们不像重视认知智能那样重视情感智能和关系智能。所以男孩们收到了关于男子气概和成熟的信息，你知道，要专注于分离而不是联系，对吧？自主独立胜过相互依赖。
It's a human need, but we gender it as feminine and so. We tell them to go underground with that. In fact, those skills are not really important, and they're not really something that we value. And I can tell you why we, I know that is because we value cognitive intelligence. We don't value emotional intelligence and relational intelligence the same way. So boys get these messages about manhood and maturity, you know, to focus on separation rather than connection, right? Autonomy independence over interdependence.
你知道，男孩们正在接受这些。当然，每个人都在接受这些。但男孩们接受得非常深刻，因为它也与男子气概联系在一起。然后他们开始断开连接，这现在是在回答你的问题。他们开始与他们想要的和他们需要的断开连接，那就是他们的友谊。
You know, boys are getting that. Of course, everybody's getting that. But boys are getting it profoundly because it's also. also linked to masculinity. And then they start to disconnect, this is now answering your question. They start to disconnect from what they want and what they need, which is their friendships.
所以他们开始转入地下，你真的可以在他们的语言中听到这一点。这太不可思议了。他们在青春期早期到中期那种柔软、美丽和感性的语言，开始听起来像一个刻板印象中的男人。没关系。我不在乎。
So they start to go under, you literally hear it in their language. It's incredible. Their language that was soft and beautiful and emotional in early to middle adolescence starts to sound like a stereotypic guy. It doesn't matter. I don't care.
没问题。一切都好。一切都好。我不需要朋友。或者如果我，你知道，那些更温柔的男孩，那些仍然愿意保持温柔的男孩，他们会说，你知道，我努力维持我的友谊。这很悲伤，因为我，你知道，我曾经拥有这些友谊。我不再拥有它们了。
It's okay. It's all good. It's all good. I don't need friends. Or if I, you know, the more tenderboard, that are willing to still be tender, they'll say things like, you know, I struggle to hold on to my friendships. It's sad because I, you know, I used to have these friendships. I no longer have them.
然后，然后他们中的一些人，这是最令人惊奇的。他们命名了“男孩文化”。他们会说，如果我是个女孩可能会很好，因为那样我就不必表现得毫无感情。我的意思是，他们指出了这一点。或者他们说，你知道，我现在长大了，你知道，我已经足够成熟了。我不需要分享我的感受。我的意思是，金，我的意思是，那不是，你知道，我想传达给我们的听众，特别是APA社区的是，这不是我关于男孩文化和男孩提出的理论。这是直接从男孩的口中说出来的。你知道我的意思吗？就像，他们直接说，在一个只重视我“硬”的一面而不重视我“软”的一面、我的软能力的环境中长大，实际上让我对自己感觉很糟糕。
And then, and then some of them, this is what's the most amazing. They name boy culture. They say things like, it might be nice to be a girl because then I wouldn't have to be emotionless. I mean, they name it. Or they say, you know, I'm grown up now, you know, I've matured enough. I don't need to share my feelings. I mean, Kim, I mean, that's, it's not, you know, what I want to communicate to our listeners, especially the APA community. It's not, this is not a theory that I'm coming up with about boy culture and boys. This is told directly from the mouse babes. You know what I mean? Like, they're saying it directly that growing up in a culture that only values my hard side and doesn't value my soft side, my soft capacities, actually causes me to feel terrible about myself.
而且往往对他人感觉很糟糕。所以这个想法是，我们需要我们的“硬”和“软”。我要说一件非常显而易见的事情。我们思考和感受。我们将思考性别化为男性，将感受性别化为女性。那是我们的第一个错误。心理学家真的必须听到这一点。这是世界上我工作最好的受众。
and oftentimes feel terrible about others. And so the idea is we need our heart and softs. I'm going to say the really obvious thing. We think and feel. We've gendered thinking as masculine and feeling as feminine. That's our first mistake. And psychologists really have to hear this. It's the best audience of my work in the world.
他们必须听到我们既思考又感受。我们想要自主和联系。我们在发展理论中已经有很长时间了。但重点是，鲍尔比（Bolby）是对的，对吧？鲍尔比当时就在谈论这个问题，关于联系和自主是相互的，你知道，它们共同作用。但在流行文化和我们抚养孩子的方式中，我们倾向于只强调“硬”的一面，尤其是对我们的男孩和年轻男性。所以这个想法是，在一个由男孩教给我们的文化中长大，成长为一种男孩文化，其中“男孩”是一个刻板印象，
They have to hear it that we think and feel. We want autonomy and connection. We've had that in developmental theory for ages. But the point is, Bolby had that right? Bulby was talking about that back in the day, about a connection and autonomy as mutually, you know, they work together. But in pop culture and the way we raise our children, we tend to only emphasize the hard side, especially with our boys and young men. So the idea is growing up in a culture taught to us by boys, growing up into a boy culture where boy is a stereotype,
实际上伤害了男孩。然后我在我的新书《叛逆者》中所说的是，它实际上伤害了我们所有人。因为现在你有了女孩，我必须说这一点，女孩们也在强调“像个男人”一样，我们实际上在我们的中国数据以及美国的模式中发现，女孩们开始比男孩更“像个男人”，这意味着她们得到了这样的信息：如果她们强调她们那种“厉害”的自我，
literally harms boys. And then what I say in my new book, Rebels, it actually harms all of us. because now you get girls, and I have to say this, girls are emphasizing manning up as two, and we're in fact finding in our data in China and as well as patterns in the United States, that girls are starting to man up more than boys, meaning they got the message that if they emphasize their sort of kick-ass self,
她们对独立的渴望和她们大声疾呼的决心——她们应该有那种决心。但如果她们只重视她们“硬”的一面，她们就能敲开大门。人们会认真对待她们。所以这个想法是，男孩文化正在伤害每个人。你知道，它只是以一种特殊的方式伤害了男孩，因为它与男子气概联系在一起，而不仅仅是成熟。但对于女孩、年轻女性和非二元性别者，我也想谈谈他们。
their desire for independence and their determination to speak out, which they should have that determination. But if they only value their hard side, they get their foot in the door. People take them seriously. And so the idea is that boy culture is hurting everybody. You know, it's just hurting boys in a particular way because it's linked to manhood and not just maturity. But for girls and young women and non-gender binary, I want to talk about them too.
非二元性别的孩子受到的影响同样严重，因为这是一种整个文化，它将我们人性的一面置于另一面之上，而我们需要人性的两面才能成为完整的人。所以它影响着我们所有人。正如你所说，你研究这个问题已经很长时间了。现在，我是在70年代的女权运动中成长起来的，我们觉得我们是在试图给男性更多的选择。这真的发生了吗？我的意思是，我们不是真的在试图给男性更多的空间去表达情感，或者对他们有更多的期待吗？这没有产生影响吗？所以从某些方面来说，这很有趣。我对这个问题有一个复杂的回答，因为我总是根据数据来回答。所以我总是必须反映数据。所以从某些方面来说，是的。所以我告诉你为什么，
Non-gender binary kids are just as impacted because it's an entire culture that privileges one side of our humanity over the other when we need both sides of our humanity to be fully human. So it's impacting all of us. As you said, you've been looking at this for a long time. now I came up during the feminist movement in the 70s, and we felt like we were trying to give men more options. Isn't that really happening? I mean, aren't we actually trying to give men more space to be emotional or expecting more of them? Isn't that sinking in? So in some ways, it's interesting. I have a complicated response to that because I actually always base my answers on data. So I always have to reflect the data. So in some ways, yes. So I'll tell you why,
数据在哪里。我们绝对，即使是这次谈话，这些关于男性友谊、男孩友谊、友谊重要性的谈话，第51分会，那是关于男性、男性和男子气概的分会吗？是的。第51分会实际上将友谊作为一种保护因素，部分基于我的工作，当然，但我认为目前我是唯一一个研究男孩友谊纵向研究的人。但重点是政策已经改变了。
where the data is. We are definitely, even this conversation, These conversations about men's friendships, boys' friendships, the importance of friendships, Division 51, is that the division for men, men and masculinity? Yeah. Division 51 actually created friendship as a protective factor based on my work, in part by my work, certainly, but I think I'm the only one at this point that's looked at longitudinal studies of friendships among boys. But the point is that policy has been changed.
你知道，我们开始认识到友谊对每个人都很重要，但对男孩和年轻男性来说尤其如此。所以我们肯定在进行政策变革，你知道，电影正在制作，奥斯卡提名的电影正在制作。我的意思是，基本上，我们开始认识到友谊很重要，不仅对女孩和女性，而且对每个人，包括男孩和男人。所以这是一个好的变化。没有改变的是——因为我们没有看到我们所处的环境，而且我说它实际上正在变得更糟——我们正在将我们的“硬”面置于“软”面之上。我们仍然以某种方式将软技能与女性气质联系起来。而我们关于女性气质的刻板印象，你会发现这很有趣，实际上
You know, we're starting to recognize that friendships matter for everybody, but for boys and young men. So we're definitely doing policy changes, you know, movies are being made, Oscar-nominated movies are being made. I mean, basically, we are starting to recognize that friendships matter, not just for girls and women, but for everybody, including boys and men. So that's a good change. What's not changed because we're not seeing the waters in which we swim, and I'm saying it's getting worse, actually, is that we're privileging our hard sides over our soft sides. We're still linking somehow soft skills with femininity. And our stereotypes about femininity, you'll be find this interesting, is actually.
变得越来越刻板，处于一种1950年代，我母亲那一代的状态。所以当我问我的纽约大学学生时——这在《叛逆者》一书中——告诉我关于男子气概和女性气质时，我的下巴都掉了，因为他们对男子气概的定义就像是负责任、聪明、坚忍、做一个好人。然后是女性气质的定义，我的意思是，里面有几个好的东西，关于善良。但基本上，它是关于肤浅、关于某种“帕蒂”（Patty），我的意思是，基本上女性气质中负面形容词的数量比男子气概中负面形容词的数量要多得多。我看着我的学生，大约40、50名学生，男人和女人，你知道，在这个特定的班级里主要是女性。我说，你们到底怎么了？
getting more stereotypic in a sort of 1950s, my mother's generation. So when I asked my NYU students, this is in the book, in Rebels, to tell me about masculinity and femininity, my jaw dropped, because their definitions of masculinity were like being responsible, being intelligent, being stoic, being a good person. And then the definitions of femininity, I mean, there was a couple good things in there about being kind. But basically, it was about being superficial, being sort of Patty, I mean, basically the number of adjectives that were negative and femininity were much more than the number of negative adjectives with masculinity. And I looked at my students about 40, 50, 50 students, men and women, you know, mostly women in this particular class. And I said, what is going on with you?
我说，你们听起来像我母亲那一代对女性气质的看法，你知道我的意思吗？某种让女性气质变得软弱，让男子气概变得强大，不仅是身体上的强大，而且是精神上的强大。你知道，我的意思是，这就像，你们到底怎么了？我认为在我们这个断开连接的社会中发生的事情是，它没有看到自己，对吧？它没有看到我们正在将“硬”置于“软”之上。我们实际上认为软技能是女性化的。我们实际上认为思考是男性化的。我的意思是，我们甚至认为它是生物学的，对吧？
I said, you guys sound like my mother's generation of femininity and, you know what I mean? Sort of making femininity weak and masculinity strong and not only strong physically, but strong mentally. You know, I mean, it's like, what is going on with you? And I think what's happening in our disconnected society that doesn't see itself, right? It doesn't see that we're privileging the heart over the soft. We actually think soft skills are feminine. We actually think thinking is masculine. I mean, we actually think it's even, we even think it's biological, right?
男人天生更聪明，女人天生在情感上更协调。我们，基本上我们只是变得更糟了。因为随着性别分歧加剧，因为我们对彼此如此愤怒，我们只是缩回到我们的性别刻板印象中。我们认为那些认同“他们”（they）的孩子——这很有趣，因为他们是一个非常激进的孩子群体，因为他们拒绝了整个性别二元论——我们认为问题在于性别代词，而不是男子气概和女性气质的定义。对我来说，这是对那些拒绝性别二元论的孩子的呼声的提升。所以我正在提升他们的声音。但我正在攻击
That men are inherently smarter and women are inherently more emotional attuned. That we, that basically we're just getting worse. Because as the gender divides and exacerbate because we're so angry at each of other, we just hunker down into our gender stereotypes. And we think that kids that are identifying with they, which is interesting because they're a very radical group of kids, because they're rejecting the whole gender binary, we're thinking the problem is the gender pronoun rather than the definitions of masculinity and femininity. And to me, that's a very, that's a lifting up of the voices of kids who have rejected the gender binary. So I'm lifting up their voices. But I'm attacking
那些仍然认同“他”和“她”的人，他们基本上已经将这些身份中最负面的刻板印象具体化了。所以我想说的最后一件事，金，作为一名女权主义者，因为我也是一名女权主义者，我是在女权主义中长大的，我有一位女权主义母亲，我的批评不是在批评男子气概。我的书不是关于批评男子气概的，因为基本上“硬”和“软”，我们的欲望，我们变得强大、坚忍、竞争，甚至用暴力保护我们的孩子的能力，对吧？你知道，我的意思是，保护他们是一件积极的事情，对吧？我们必要时反击的能力，那是一件积极的事情。
the people who still identify with he and she that basically have reified, reified the most negative stereotypes with those identities. And so the final thing I want to say, Kim, my critique as a feminist, because I too am a feminist, I was raised as a feminist, I had a feminist mother, is that I'm not critiquing masculinity. My book is not about critiquing masculinity because basically the hard and the soft, our desire, our capacity to be strong and stoic and competitive and even to defend our children with violence, right? You know, I mean, defend them is a positive thing, right? Our capacity to fight back when we need to fight back, that's a positive thing.
我所批评的是一种只重视那种能力，而不重视那种能力——金，对你的感受敏感，真正关心你的想法和感受，真正想要联系并保持好奇，在人际关系上对你的经历感到好奇的能力。我们甚至在心理学中不研究这一点。我们甚至不认为人际好奇心是一回事。你知道，我的意思是，这太不可思议了，但它是所有人际联系的根源。这就是男孩文化有多么断开连接，因为我们重视智力好奇心胜过
What I'm critiquing is a culture that only values that capacity and not the capacity, Kim, to be sensitive to your feelings and to actually care about what you think and feel and to actually want to connect and be curious, interpersonally curious about your experiences. We don't even study that in psychology. We don't even think interpersonal curiosity is a thing. You know, I mean, it's incredible, but it's at the root of all human connection. And that's how disconnected boy culture is because we value intellectual curiosity over
人际好奇心。我们现在正要进行心理学领域关于人际好奇心发展的第一次研究，金，想想这意味着什么。你连接他人所需的技能，那种女性化的技能——它不是女性化的，但它被女性化了。这是一种人类技能。发展心理学家甚至还没有认真对待它。所以对我来说，这确实是一个我们没有看到的文化问题，而且我们在那方面已经变得
interpersonal. And we're now about to do the very first study of the development of interpersonal curiosity in the field of psychology, Kim, and think what that means. The very skill that you need to connect to other people, the feminine skill, it's what's not feminine, but it's been feminized. It's a human skill. Developmental psychologists haven't even taken. seriously. So to me, it's really is a cultural problem that we're not seeing, and we've gotten
更糟了。我们要休息一下，回来后，我们将与韦博士讨论为什么一些男孩在学校和职场中在具体方面挣扎，以及这是否与男孩文化有关。我们看到的是，男孩们正在挣扎，他们在学校、职场和人生里程碑的一些非常具体的方面落后于女孩。那么为什么会发生这种情况？这与男孩文化有什么联系？这是一个非常简单的故事。这一切都归结为男孩文化，即如果你只将“硬”置于“软”之上，这意味着你只重视“硬”的职业和“硬”的学科。我们已经知道，硬科学、STEM领域和商业领域胜过其他一切，但肯定胜过护理、教学、
worse in that respect. We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll talk with Dr. Way about why some boys are struggling in concrete ways in school and the workforce, and whether that's tied to boy culture. What we're seeing is that boys are struggling and they're falling behind girls in some very concrete ways in school and the workforce, life milestones. So why is that is that happening? And how is that tied to boy culture? It's a very simple story. It all comes down to boy culture, which is if you only privilege the hard over the soft, that means you only privilege the hard professions and the hard disciplines. And we already know that the hard sciences, stem fields and business fields over everything else, but certainly over nursing, teaching,
心理学，我的意思是，所有这些，你随便说，不是心理学中的神经科学，而是，你知道，心理学的软形式，临床应用心理学。所以这个想法是，我们在一切事物中都有“硬”胜过“软”，一切，一切，不仅是我们人类的思考和感受，而且在我们的职业和学科中。如果你有一个世界，进入软职业、教学等等，对诗歌和人文科学感兴趣——我要说一些听起来很荒谬的话，但这就是我们作为一个文化变得多么不聪明——如果我们认为那是“女孩气”的事情，对吧，想要成为一名教师，或者想要成为一名护士，或者想要写作，或者想要写诗。我的意思是，想想我们世界的历史，我们认为想要写诗是一件
psychology, I mean, all, you name it, and not neuroscience in psychology, but, you know, the soft form of psychology, clinical applied psychology. So the idea is that we have a heart over soft in everything, everything, everything, not just our human thinking and feeling, but in our professions and in our disciplines. And if you have a world in which going into the soft professions, teaching, et cetera, being interested in poetry and humanities, I'm going to say something that sounds ridiculous, but this is how unintelligent we've become as a culture. If we think that's a girly thing, right, to want to be a teacher or to want to be a nurse or to want to write or to want to write poetry. I mean, think about the history of our world that we think it's a
“女孩气”的事情。如果我们认为它与性别认同有关，那不仅会对女孩和女性造成伤害，还会对男孩和男人造成伤害。大学变得不那么有趣了。而且我要把这一点放在一边，大学也贵得离谱。所以对于所有工人阶级的男孩和年轻男性，甚至中产阶级的男孩和年轻男性，他们负担不起大学，然后看到如果我甚至不做让我赚钱的专业，我为什么要上大学？所以我先把这一点放在一边，因为这显然也在发生。就像，如果我对STEM和商业不感兴趣，我为什么要上大学，对吧？但是，你知道，它不会帮我赚钱，所以我还不如现在就开始赚钱。但即使我们以富家子弟为例，现实是，上大学，你所能做的能让你成功并能让你有体面薪水的选择现在仅限于STEM领域和商业。我如何证明我的观点是，我们有很多项目让女孩和女性进入STEM领域。我们什么都没有，什么都没有，让男孩和男人进入软职业，你知道，进入护理、教学、社会工作。
girly thing to want to write poetry. If we think it's a link to a gender identity, that's going to not only be damaging to girls and women, it's going to be damaging to boys and men. And college becomes less interesting. And I'm going to put aside, college is also obscenely expensive. So for all working class boys and young men or even middle class boys and young men who can't afford college and then see if I'm not even going to do a major that allows me to make money, why would I even go to college? So I'm going to put that aside for a second because that's obviously going on too. Like, why would I go to college if I'm not interested in STEM and going into business, right? But, you know, it's not going to help me make money, so I might as well just
我的意思是，我们没有任何东西来鼓励他们，当然特别是少数族裔男性，去从事这些我们迫切需要的职业。所以这解释了大学的问题。这解释了为什么男人在找工作时更困难，因为如果你每小时只挣10美元，你为什么要从事教学？我的意思是，显然，我在夸大其词，但重点是我们不仅不重视这些职业，
start making money now. But even if we take the rich kids, the reality is that going to college, your assortment of what you can do that will make you successful and that will allow you to have actually a decent salary is now limited to the STEM fields and business. And how I can prove my point is that we have lots of programs to get girls and women into STEM fields. We have nothing, nothing, to get boys and men into the soft professions, you know, into nursing, into teaching, into social work.
我们不支付他们生活工资。所以如果你拿不到生活工资，你为什么要从事这些职业？女性仍然能想出办法，但部分原因是，你知道，如果她们是上层阶级，她们往往能得到父母的帮助，对吧？她们能得到父母的帮助，或者她们能得到伴侣的帮助。我的意思是，性别动态就是这样发挥作用的，以至于男人更有责任带回大钱，这样女人就可以做一些赚不到多少钱的事情。我们仍然有那种性别动态。所以这确实解释了它，对吧？
I mean, we have nothing to encourage them, especially men of color, of course, to do these professions that we are desperately in need of. So it explains the college thing. It explains why men are having a harder time finding work, because why would you go into teaching if you get paid $10 an hour? I mean, obviously, I'm exaggerating, but the point is we not only don't value these professions,
我想说最后一件事，我没有说。关于男孩文化的一件事，这是一个重要的点，我总是忘记这一点，这是一个关键点。它不仅是人类品质的等级制度，它也是人类的等级制度，我们都在试图爬到顶端。所以如果你有一个人类的等级制度，其中一些人被认为比其他人更有价值，所以男人高于女人，富人高于穷人，白人高于有色人种，我的意思是，如果你有那种社会，我们都在试图爬到顶端，那是男孩文化的一部分，对吧？因为它顺便说一句是一个极其不成熟的等级制度。所以我是在暗示它的不成熟，我们认为有些人比其他人更值得关怀。这会导致伤害，因为特朗普的支持者，你知道这一点，金，特朗普的支持者觉得他们被置于等级制度的底层，
we don't pay them a living wage. So why would you go into them if you're not getting paid a living wage? Women still figure it out, but in part because, you know, they oftentimes have the help from their parents if they're upper class, right? They have help from their parents or they can have help from a partner. I mean, just the gender dynamics just play out in that so that it becomes more of the responsibility for the man to bring in the big bucks so that the woman can do something that doesn't make very much money. And we still have that gender dynamic. So that really explains it, right?
他们的需求无关紧要。特朗普说，嘿，你很重要，你很重要。你知道，就像，我要，他不会，他没有，他没有这样做。但我只是说他的言论是，你很重要。所以对我来说，就像我们必须打破这种等级制度。而且，你知道，这就是男孩和年轻男性教给我们的，这不是某个群体的错。是我们整个文化创造了一种文化，它说如果我是个女孩可能会很好，因为那样我就不必表现得毫无感情。
And I want to say one final thing that I didn't say. One of the thing that's about a boy culture, and this is an important point, I always forget this and it's a critical point. Inibetta is not only a hierarchy of human qualities, it's a hierarchy of humans where we're all trying to get on top. And so if you have a hierarchy of humans where some people are considered more valuable than other humans, so men over women, rich over poor, white people over people of color, I mean, if you have that kind of society where we're all trying to get on top, that's part of boy culture, right? Because it's a deeply immature hierarchy, by the way. And so I'm alluding to the immaturity of it that we think some humans are more worthy of care than others. that's going to cause damage because the Trump supporters, you know this, Kim, the Trump supporters felt like they were being put on the bottom of a hierarchy,
而且只有重视，你知道，女权主义者也这样做。我会责怪我自己的群体。我们试图颠覆等级制度，把自己放在顶端，把其他人放在底层。那可能在当下感觉很好。它不会解决长期问题。它不会解决暴力，因为没有人想成为人类等级制度的底层。当他们能接触到武器时，正如我总是告诉我的学生，不幸的是，他们可能会试图杀了你。对，因为没有人想被置于底层。我们从大规模枪击案凶手那里学到了这一点，
that their needs didn't matter. And Trump said, hey, you matter, you matter. You know, like, I'm going to, he's not going to, he didn't, he's not doing it. But I'm just saying his rhetoric was, you matter. And so to me, it's like we have to disrupt the hierarchy. And, you know, and that's what boys and young men teach us is that it's not, it's not someone's group's fault. It's our whole culture that's creating a culture that says it might be nice to be a girl because then I wouldn't have to be emotionless.
顺便说一句，金。现在，你花了很多时间和精力研究有色人种的男孩和男人以及那些来自工人阶级背景的人。为什么要关注这些群体？因为他们讲述了一个故事。心理学家知道这一点，社会学家肯定也知道这一点。往往那些不在权力中心的人讲述的事情最有洞察力。我早在我还是哈佛大学人类发展博士生时就学到了这一点，当时我在波士顿的公立学校工作，往往你会得到的故事，你知道，即使是《深层秘密》，它部分基于我在波士顿的研究，他们讲述了一个更真实的故事，因为他们看到了自己。
And that it's the only valuing, you know, feminists do this too. I'll blame my own group. We try to flip the hierarchy and put ourselves on top and other people on bottom. That may feel good at the moment. It's not going to solve the long-term problem. It's not going to solve the violence because nobody wants to be on the bottom of a hierarchy of humanists. And when they have access to weapons, as I always tell my students, unfortunately, they might try to kill you. right, because nobody wants to be put on the bottom. And we learned that from mass shooters,
就像白人、富有的男人有时很难看到自己，因为他们是常态，所以，你知道，他们看不到自己的特权。他们看不到，你知道，他们也被男孩文化伤害的方式，顺便说一句。他们看不到它。但当你与处于边缘的男孩和年轻男性交谈时，我称之为处于权力边缘的人，按种族、社会阶级、我们拥有的各种分歧，他们更愿意对权力说真话。他们看到了。
by the way, Kim. Now, you've spent a lot of time and effort studying boys and men of color and those from working class backgrounds. Why focus on those groups? It's because they tell a story. Psychologists know this and sociologists definitely know this. Oftentimes the people that are not in the center of power tell the most insightful things. And I learned that early in the day when I was a doctoral student in human development at Harvard and I was working in public schools in Boston, that oftentimes the stories you would get, you know, even deep secrets that was written off based of, in part, my studies in Boston, they tell a story that's more truth-telling because they see themselves.
他们看到了。他们感觉到了，因为他们生活在其中。你知道，如果我是个女孩可能会很好，因为那样我就不必表现得毫无感情。你知道，我们现在可能在白人特权男孩中得到这一点，因为它已经成为文化的一部分。但通常我们不会，我不认为我在80年代末、90年代初会得到那些数据，当时男孩们对“硬”胜过“软”的特权，以及当然还有人类等级制度非常清楚，因为他们，你知道，
It's like white, rich men sometimes have a hard time seeing themselves because they're the norm so that, you know, they don't see their own privilege. They don't see the way, you know, the way they've been damaged by boy culture too, by the way. They don't see it. But when you talk to boys and young men on the fringe, what I call on the fringe of power, by race, by social class, by all sorts of divisions we have, they're much more willing to speak truth to power. They see it.
他们被置于底层。所以他们基本上意识到是什么让他们在外部世界、在白人世界、在富人世界中，某种程度上无法接触到顶端。所以这个想法是，对我来说，工人阶级的年轻人和有色人种的孩子，我想对所有心理学家说，他们往往告诉我们主流心理学没有讲述的故事，因为我们太关注了，即使现在，尽管我知道我们在过去二十年中已经多样化了，即使现在我们仍然严重地将我们的发展研究集中在特权社区的孩子身上，对吧，在各种美国特权社区中，有时它是种族多样化的，但重点是它在社会经济上是中产阶级和上层阶级。
They see it. They feel it because they live it. You know, it might be nice to be a girl because then I wouldn't have to be emotionless. You know, we may now get that among white privileged boys because it's been so part of the, you know, the culture. But usually what we don't, I don't think I would have gotten that data back in the, you know, in the late 80s, early 90s, where boys had been so clear about the privileging of the heart over soft, but also the hierarchy of humanness, of course, because they're, you know,
所以这个想法是，当我们限制它时，不仅仅是我们错过了领域中的声音，我们错过了——这是一个大问题，金——我们错过了关于人类发展的见解，这些见解是必要的。我们唯一能对历史和我们对自己的理解有新见解的方式，就是通过倾听不是我们自己的人。对吧？
they've been put on the bottom. And so they're basically aware of what keeps them in the outside world, in the white world, and the rich world, sort of not having access to the top. So the idea is that to me, the working class young people and the kids of color, and I want to say this to all psychologists, they oftentimes tell us the story that mainstream psychology has not told, because we've been focused too much, even now, even though I know we've diversified in the last two decades, even now we still heavily focus our developmental research on kids in privileged communities, right, in various kinds of American privileged communities, sometimes it's racially diverse, but the point of it's socioeconomically middle and upper class.
我的意思是，我父亲说，我想用我父亲的另一个见解来结束对这个问题的回答，实际上。我18岁时，我对美国青少年很感兴趣。我一直对美国青少年很感兴趣。他说，尼奥比，如果你对美国
So the idea is when we limit it, it's not just that we're missing voices in the field, we're missing, and this is a big thing, Kim, we're missing insights about human development that are necessary. The only way we're going to have new insights in the history in our understanding of ourselves is by listening to people that are not ourselves. Right?
青少年感兴趣，去中国住住。他的观点是，如果你只看到你自己，你就看不到你自己，对吧？你必须看到某样东西，某个人，对吧，不是某样东西。你必须看到与你不同的人才能看到你自己。而心理学家——我要批评心理学领域的一些方面，特别是研究心理学，特别是发展心理学——是我们假设如果我们能看到自己，那会让我们成为更好的研究者。但现实是，对吧，我们做那种匹配的事情。但现实是，我们未能理解，我们将看到更多的自己。不仅仅是他们。
I mean, my father said, I want to end with one, I mean, end to the response with one more insight from my father, actually. He said when I was 18, I was interested in American adolescents. I've always been interested in American adolescents. And he said, Niobe, if you're interested in American
如果我们是白人，我们不会更多地看到有色人种的孩子。通过倾听有色人种的孩子，我们实际上会更多地看到我们自己。通过倾听不是我的人，对吧，并且没有相同背景的人，我们会理解人类发展，事实上理解作为“我”意味着什么。所以对我来说，这是心理学中的一个重要点。对有色人种和来自工人阶级家庭的孩子的学习，不仅仅是对有色人种和工人阶级家庭孩子的学习。它们是对人类的学习，是对作为人类意味着什么以及什么阻碍了我们成为人类的能力的学习。我希望我们在该领域改变这一点，以便我们理解，包括女性，对吧，正如卡罗尔·吉利根（Carol Gilligan）几十年前所说，不仅仅是关于女性。
adolescence go live in China. And his point was, you can't see yourself if you only see yourself, right? You have to see something, someone, right, not something. You have to see people who are different from you to see yourself. And psychologists, I'm going to, I'm going to critique the field of psychology in some ways, especially research psychology, especially developmental psychology, is that we have assumed that if we can see ourselves, that makes us a better researcher. But the reality, right, we do that sort of matching thing. But the reality is we fail to understand that we will see ourselves even more. Not just them.
它是关于成为人类。她出了一本书叫《以人类的声音》，因为这个想法是，关系的声音不是女性的声音。它是人类的声音。我们倾向于将非主流的声音视为他们独特的，而不看到与我们的相关性。但我认为那是该领域的一个大错误。刚才，你提到了去中国，你也确实去了。你在中国做了一些研究。你发现这与你在美国看到的情况相似吗？是否存在真正显著的文化差异？还是男人和男孩在那种文化中也有同样的问题？首先，我父亲是一位中国学者。
We won't see kids of color more if we're white. We'll actually see ourselves more by listening to kids of color. We'll understand human development and in fact of what it means to be me by listening to kids who aren't me, right, and who don't have the same background. And so to me, it's an important point in psychology. The studies of kids of color and from working class families are not just studies of kids of color and working class families. They are studies of humans and what it means to be human and what's getting in the way of our capacity to be human. And I want us to shift that in the field so that we understand that including women, right, as Carol Gilligan said decades ago, is not just about women.
所以我从1985年就开始去中国了。他在80年代在那里住了八年。我学到了很多。他现在已经去世了，但我学到了很多关于中国历史的知识。我现在对中国了如指掌，因为我父亲是一位文学教授和艺术专家，他抚养我长大。但他总是说，基本上欧洲人剽窃了中国贡献的大部分，
It's about being human. She came out with a book called In a Human Voice because the idea is the relational voice is not a women's voice. It's a human voice. And we tend to take the non-mainstream and make their voices distinct to them and not see relevance to us. But that's the big mistake in the field, I would argue. A moment ago, you mentioned going to China and you've done that. You've done some research in China. Are you finding that similar to what you're seeing in the U.S. are there cultural differences that are really salient? Or is men and boys having the same issues in that culture as well? First of all, my father was a China scholar.
并声称它是欧洲的。所以我就是这样长大的。你知道我的意思吗？带着一种从未得到认可的文化实际上是欧洲启蒙运动基础的感觉。无论如何，在花了很多时间在中国之后，然后我开始与广吉川（Hiro Yoshikawa）和其他人以及陈新燕（Shinyan Chen）进行一项研究，两位发展心理学家广吉川和陈新燕。我们从2006年开始。这是一项针对1200个家庭的研究，既有青少年队列
So I've been going to China since 1985. He lived there for eight years in the 80s. I've learned a lot. He's passed now, but I've learned a lot about the history of China. I know China, like the back of my hand at this point, having raised by a father who was inculcating that he was a literature professor and art specialist. But he was always saying basically the Europeans ripped off most of what China contributed
我从1985年就开始去中国了。他在80年代在那里住了八年。我学到了很多。他现在已经去世了，但我对中国的历史了解颇深。我父亲是一位文学教授和艺术专家，他从小就教导我，所以我现在对中国了如指掌。但他总是说，欧洲人基本上剽窃了中国的大部分贡献，
and claimed it to be European. So that's how I was raised. You know what I mean? with the sense of like this culture that's never been given the credit was actually at the basis of the Enlightenment for Europe. Anyway, so in that spending so much time in China, and then I began a study with Hiro Yoshikawa and others and Shinyan Chen, two developmental psychologists by Hiro Yoshikawa and Shinian Chen. We started it in 2006. It's a study of 1,200 families, both an adolescent cohort
并声称那是欧洲的。我就是这样长大的。你明白我的意思吗？这种文化从未得到应有的认可，而它实际上是欧洲启蒙运动的基础。总之，在花了很多时间在中国之后，我开始与两位发展心理学家——广吉川（Hiro Yoshikawa）和陈新艳（音译，Shinyan Chen）等人进行研究。我们从2006年开始，这是一项针对1200个家庭的研究，其中包括一个青少年群体。
and a baby cohort, and we're still, we're about to do the 20-year follow-up of both samples. So we even went into the hospitals in 2006, and we actually interviewed parents and observed babies when they were born, and they're now 20 years old. And with adolescents, we've been doing repeated follow-ups, and we finally got a grant, external grant, we've been funding it ourselves and all sorts of ways. 1,200 families looking at the social economic context and how it shapes child development. And so we're about to do this 20-year follow-ups. So to get to your question. So we have about 800 adolescents we've been following, and then we have about 500 families of babies that we've been following and who are now young adults. So what we find in our data is this is something that's very depressing for me, especially because I know China from the 80s, right, which gives me some good insight.
还有一个婴儿队列，我们正准备对这两个样本进行20年的随访。我们在2006年进入医院，采访了父母并观察了刚出生的婴儿，他们现在已经20岁了。对于青少年，我们一直在进行重复随访，最终我们获得了一笔外部资助，之前我们都是自筹资金，通过各种方式维持。我们研究了1200个家庭，观察社会经济背景如何塑造儿童发展。我们正准备进行这20年的随访。回到你的问题，我们一直在追踪大约800名青少年，以及大约500个婴儿家庭，他们现在已经是年轻人了。我们的数据发现了一些让我感到非常沮丧的事情，尤其是因为我了解80年代的中国，这让我有一些深刻的见解。
Basically, China from the 1980s when I lived there in 1985 to when I lived there in 2007, because I ended up going there for a long time to just collect the data with a huge team. We work with a huge team, is that China has become more American-fied. I mean, just American culture is dominant. In 1987, I'll give you an example, men held hands. It wasn't a sexual thing. It was just a human thing that you saw men holding hands all the time, hugging each other, being very physically, even kissing each other. I mean, basically friends.
基本上，从我1985年居住的中国到2007年我居住的中国，因为我后来在那里待了很长时间，与一个庞大的团队一起收集数据。我们与一个庞大的团队合作，发现中国变得更加“美国化”了。我的意思是，美国文化占据了主导地位。举个例子，1987年，男性会手牵手。这并不是什么性行为，这只是一种人类的自然行为，你经常看到男性手牵手、拥抱，甚至亲吻，基本上就是朋友。
They were friends. And when I went back in 2007 and lived there with my little kids, you never saw that, because that had been identified as gay behavior. So you never saw that, right? You never saw that. And so the idea is you start to see, you know, now masculinity in China traditionally was about being learned in the traditional sense, knowing poetry, knowing literature, knowing philosophy, right? Being strong, of course, because that's always been a part of masculinity, but everywhere in the world. But in China, it was really about knowing the world, knowing art, right? Being basically an educated person was part of masculinity.
他们是朋友。当我2007年带着我的小孩子回到那里生活时，你再也看不到这种情况了，因为那被定义为同性恋行为。所以你再也看不到了，对吧？你再也看不到了。所以现在的观念是，你开始看到，你知道，中国传统的男子气概在于传统意义上的博学，懂诗词、懂文学、懂哲学，对吧？当然也要强壮，因为这在世界各地都是男子气概的一部分。但在中国，它确实关乎了解世界、了解艺术，对吧？基本上，做一个受过教育的人是男子气概的一部分。
And then starting in about, I'm estimated, this is now in my opinion having lived there, starting in about 2000, when the sort of American culture came in, sports culture came in, you know, basketball, they had Yao Ming who was playing basketball. It started to come in and you literally saw the infiltration of American masculinity into China. You also saw, I'll tell you another example. In communism, communism as a theory, believes that, you know, men and women hold up half the sky. they believe in gender equality. Theoretically, I'm not saying there was gender equality, God forbid.
然后大约从2000年开始，据我估计，这是我作为一个在那里生活过的人的观点，随着美国文化的进入，体育文化的进入，你知道，篮球，他们有姚明在打篮球。它开始渗透，你确实看到了美国式的男子气概渗透到了中国。你还看到了，我再告诉你一个例子。在共产主义理论中，认为男人和女人能顶半边天，他们相信性别平等。从理论上讲，我并不是说当时真的实现了性别平等，天哪。
But I'm just saying theoretically that was gender equality was the theory of communism. And so when we would interview parents in 2006, they always talked about boys and girls are the same, that they have the same needs. And, you know, even though they privileged boys over girls, certainly at that time, they always talked about boys and girls being the same. when we interviewed the same age, but different parents 10 years later in our baby sample, they were, the whole dialogue, Kim, is about the differences between boys and girls. And boys have, you know, aren't as socially, emotionally competent as girls. And, you know, I mean, all the gender stereotypes that we have in the United States were being repeated.
我只是说从理论上讲，性别平等是共产主义的理论。所以当我们在2006年采访父母时，他们总是说男孩和女孩是一样的，他们有相同的需求。而且，你知道，尽管当时他们确实在某种程度上偏袒男孩，但他们总是说男孩和女孩是一样的。当我们10年后在我们的婴儿样本中采访同龄但不同的父母时，整个对话，Kim，都是关于男孩和女孩之间的差异。男孩没有女孩那么强的社会情感能力。而且，你知道，我的意思是，我们在美国所拥有的所有性别刻板印象都在被重复。
Kim, it was stunning to hear. They were repeating our stereotypes. And the reason why the longitudinal data is, is so stunning is I didn't hear that in the parents in 2006 of adolescence. I heard it in the parents of adolescence in 2016, where they sounded American. They literally sounded American in their gender stereotypes. And so now you're getting schools in China. I mean, it's stunning that is trying to prevent boys from acting like girls, right? So being so soft. And you're getting entire schools that have curriculum to enhance masculinity in an American sense of what masculinity means,
Kim，听到这些真是令人震惊。他们正在重复我们的刻板印象。纵向数据之所以如此令人震惊，是因为我在2006年青少年的父母身上没有听到这些。我在2016年青少年的父母身上听到了，他们听起来就像美国人。他们在性别刻板印象上听起来简直就是美国人。所以现在中国的学校，我的意思是，这太令人震惊了，正在试图阻止男孩表现得像女孩，对吧？也就是不要那么柔弱。整个学校都有课程来增强美国意义上的男子气概，
meaning playing sports, being fit, being built, right? And basically valuing math and science and, you know, business. I mean, it's like, oh my God. You know, and to see that change in the culture is really what the impetus with writing Rebels with the Cause, my latest book, because I realized I have literally witnessed the change because I happened to have a father living in China in the 80s. And then I went back to China to live there for a while.
意思是参加体育运动、保持健康、强壮，对吧？基本上重视数学、科学和商业。我的意思是，天哪。你知道，看到文化中的这种变化，确实是我写《Rebels with the Cause》这本最新书的动力，因为我意识到我亲眼目睹了这种变化，因为我父亲在80年代住在那里，后来我又回到中国住了一段时间。
and I could literally see the change and then we saw in our data, in our 20-year data. So I would say yes, the answer, now the answer to your question is absolutely we see the same patterns because it stems from we have given a gender identity to thinking and feeling. And that is our first mistake. If you make thinking masculine and feeling feminine, you know, a sister from another planet Kim, right, would look at us and say, what's wrong with you people? You know, what's wrong with you people? How can you create a thrive?
我确实看到了这种变化，然后在我们的20年数据中也看到了。所以我说，是的，现在回答你的问题，我们绝对看到了同样的模式，因为它源于我们给思考和感受赋予了性别身份。这是我们的第一个错误。如果你把思考定义为男性化，把感受定义为女性化，你知道，一个来自外星的姐妹，Kim，会对我们说，你们这些人怎么了？你知道，你们这些人怎么了？你们怎么能创造一个繁荣的社会？
I mean, I'm sounding a little silly at the moment, but I'm just getting the profundity of it. You know, that boys and young men are saying, don't give a gender identity of thinking and feeling. It's a human thing. It's not a gender identity, right? To want friendships is not a gender identity, right? To want emotionally intimate connections, relationships does not have a gender identity. It's a human need and a human capacity. And think about all the history of friendships we have in the Western.
我的意思是，我此刻听起来有点傻，但我只是在表达它的深刻性。你知道，男孩和年轻男性在说，不要给思考和感受赋予性别身份。这是一种人类的特质。这不是性别身份，对吧？渴望友谊不是一种性别身份，对吧？渴望情感上的亲密联系和关系并没有性别身份。这是一种人类的需求和能力。想想我们在西方历史上所有的友谊。
tradition, Aristotle. I mean, we have a whole history of male friendships that we valued, right, in the history of the Western world, same in the Eastern world. You have the whole history of male friendships being valued. And somehow in the 20th century, we began to give it a gender identity, you know, which is just fascinating to me. Let's switch gears a little bit and talk about possible solutions. Because in your recent work, you have been looking at ways to help people stay more connected with each other, including what you call listening with curiosity. So what does that mean and why is it important? What we tried to do about 10 years ago with my colleague Joseph Nelson, who's now a full professor at Swarthmore, he was a former student of mine a long time ago,
传统，亚里士多德。我的意思是，我们在西方世界的历史上有一整段我们珍视的男性友谊的历史，对吧？东方世界也是一样。你有一整段男性友谊被珍视的历史。不知何故，在20世纪，我们开始给它赋予了性别身份，你知道，这对我来说太迷人了。让我们换个话题，谈谈可能的解决方案。因为在你最近的工作中，你一直在寻找帮助人们保持更紧密联系的方法，包括你所说的“带着好奇心倾听”。那么这意味着什么，为什么它很重要？大约10年前，我和我的同事Joseph Nelson尝试这样做，他现在是斯沃斯莫尔学院的正教授，他很久以前曾是我的学生，
we decided to do the method that I had been interviewing in, and Joseph and I had been teaching in, we were teaching the method of listening with curiosity. We didn't call it that at the time, with doctoral students to do their dissertations. And I've been teaching it since 2000, sorry, 1999, and he's been teaching it with me for the past 10 years or so. And we would get in that class with doctoral students when we teach this method of listening as to do an interview project for your dissertation,
我们决定采用我一直在采访中使用的，也是Joseph和我一直在教授的方法，我们当时在教“带着好奇心倾听”的方法。我们当时并没有这样称呼它，我们是教博士生如何完成他们的论文。我从2000年，抱歉，1999年就开始教这个方法了，他过去10年左右一直和我一起教。当我们教这种倾听方法作为论文采访项目时，我们会和博士生一起上课，
we would get the feedback like, Dr. Way, you realize that it's not just a research method. It totally changes your relationship. relationships when you learn the method. And I would be like, I was sort of passing it off as like, okay, okay, that's interesting, but I wasn't really thinking about it. And then the boys, the deep secrets came out and people said, how did you get boys to talk like that? Like, you know what I mean? Because so many of the quotes are so gorgeous. And they said, how did you get boys to talk like that? And I was like, it wasn't a secret potion. It was really a method that I learned in part from Carol
我们会得到这样的反馈：“Way博士，你意识到这不仅仅是一种研究方法吗？当你学会这个方法时，它完全改变了你的人际关系。”我会说，我当时只是把它当作“好吧，好吧，这很有趣”，但我并没有真正去思考它。然后男孩们，那些深层的秘密出来了，人们说，你是怎么让男孩那样说话的？你知道我的意思吗？因为很多引语都太美了。他们说，你是怎么让男孩那样说话的？我说，这不是什么秘密药水。这确实是我从Carol
Gilligan and Lynn Michael Brown at Harvard when I was a doctoral student. And it was really a way of listening with curiosity to what they were saying rather than just basically going through an interview protocol or just affirming my stereotypes by, for example, I'll give example, because I'm speaking to a psychologist, for example, not following up on the questions where they reveal a kind of vulnerability with their friends. What we would do as psychologists is we wouldn't follow up with that if we were interviewing them because we think that we wouldn't even hear the story because we're looking for the way we think boys relate to each other, which is just through sports and whatever it is. So we wouldn't even follow up with that question.
Gilligan和哈佛大学的Lynn Michael Brown那里学到的方法，当时我还是博士生。这确实是一种带着好奇心去倾听他们所说内容的方式，而不是仅仅走过场进行采访，或者通过确认我的刻板印象来验证，例如，我举个例子，因为我是在和一位心理学家交谈，例如，不追问他们表现出对朋友脆弱性的问题。作为心理学家，如果我们采访他们，我们不会追问，因为我们认为我们甚至听不到那个故事，因为我们正在寻找我们认为男孩之间相处的方式，即仅仅通过体育运动等等。所以我们甚至不会追问那个问题。
But when, you know, right? So the idea is that the method is really about listening with curiosity to what they're saying to understand how they see themselves, not how we stereotype them to be. Then in about 2015, Joseph and I had this big insight together. Why are we just teaching it to doctoral students? Why aren't we teaching it to young people so they can actually have the relationships that they want? So we went into this boys school in the Lower East side. We started to teach it to seventh graders, 12-year-olds.
但是，你知道，对吧？所以这个想法是，这种方法确实是带着好奇心去倾听他们所说的话，以了解他们如何看待自己，而不是我们如何刻板地看待他们。然后在2015年左右，Joseph和我一起有了这个重大的洞察。为什么我们只教给博士生？为什么我们不教给年轻人，让他们能够真正拥有他们想要的关系？所以我们去了下东区的一所男校。我们开始教七年级的学生，12岁的孩子。
and we were blown away because guess what, Kim, they were better at it than the doctoral students because it's connected to your natural curiosity and we stamp the curiosity out of our students. So they basically by the time they're doctoral students, they have no more curiosity. And they're only about what's a good question rather than what's a real question. So we had the doctoral students interview that seventh graders as part of the lesson in the first time we taught it to seventh graders. And the doctoral students were stunned. They said the seventh graders are so much better than we are.
我们感到非常震惊，因为猜猜怎么着，Kim，他们比博士生做得更好，因为它与你天生的好奇心相连，而我们扼杀了学生的好奇心。所以他们到博士生阶段时，已经没有好奇心了。他们只关心什么是好问题，而不是什么是真正的问题。所以我们让博士生采访七年级的学生，作为我们第一次教七年级学生课程的一部分。博士生们惊呆了。他们说七年级的学生比我们好多了。
And I said, and that was our big insight that basically this curiosity that we're born with our five-year-old curiosity is our secret sauce, Kim, to human connection. Because it's about actually listening with wonder and curiosity about what not only, and remember, this leads back to the other theme. Not only what you experience and how you define love and all the things that we care about, trust and relationships and friendships, but it helps me understand by listening to you, Kim, how I define. that. Because ultimately, as you talk about what you mean by a close friendship, I begin to understand what I mean because I'm comparing, right, my response to your response. So sometimes there'll be similarities, but sometimes there'll be differences that's, you know, that's clarifying for me as I listen. So I'm not saying at the point of listening with curiosity is just to learn about yourself, but I'm saying to recognize that you learn about yourself through listening to somebody else.
我说，这就是我们的重大洞察，基本上我们与生俱来的五岁孩子般的好奇心是我们人类联系的秘诀，Kim。因为它实际上是关于带着惊奇和好奇心去倾听，不仅是，记住，这回到了另一个主题。不仅是你经历什么，你如何定义爱，以及我们关心的所有事情，信任、关系和友谊，而且它通过倾听你，Kim，帮助我理解我如何定义这些。因为最终，当你谈论你所说的亲密友谊时，我开始理解我的意思，因为我在比较，对吧，我的反应和你的反应。所以有时会有相似之处，但有时会有差异，这在我倾听时对我来说是澄清。所以我并不是说带着好奇心倾听的重点只是为了了解你自己，而是说要认识到你通过倾听别人来了解自己。
And we are such a disconnected culture that we think connection is just talking about ourselves. It's not. We don't form connection through talking about ourselves. So we're all talking about ourselves, you know, thinking it's going to form connection. And of course, it doesn't. And any five-year-old would say, why would that form connection to just share your story? We have to actually be curious in each other's stories. So the Listening with Curiosity Project, we've done it. I'll do this very quickly. We've done it for about eight years now. We got funded by Spencer Foundation, Chan Zuckerberg initiative, who basically invested in it and said, build a curriculum around it for schools. We built a 26 lesson curriculum. We've been doing it in schools. We have great impact.
我们是一个如此脱节的文化，以至于我们认为联系只是谈论我们自己。事实并非如此。我们不是通过谈论自己来建立联系的。所以我们都在谈论自己，你知道，认为这会形成联系。当然，它不会。任何五岁孩子都会说，仅仅分享你的故事怎么会形成联系呢？我们必须真正对彼此的故事感到好奇。所以“带着好奇心倾听”项目，我们已经做了。我很快地说一下。我们已经做了大约八年了。我们获得了斯宾塞基金会、陈-扎克伯格倡议的资助，他们基本上投资了它，并说，围绕它为学校建立课程。我们建立了一个26课时的课程。我们一直在学校里做。我们有很大的影响。
impact. We've been publishing on it. You can find our work just by looking at my name. And we find that fostering curiosity is linked to all sorts of social emotional skills as well-being, as well as academic engagement, as well as a sense of a common humanity. It improves a sense of connectedness to others who are not, who are different from you. So interpersonal curiosity, we're now creating a whole institute called the Social Health Institute that's going to be training people in the framework and method around, we want to get it. It's a virtual institute. around the world because we have so many educators and parents and kids who want to be trained in the method and the framework. So we're building that. And the final thing I want to say is we're
影响。我们一直在发表相关文章。你只需搜索我的名字就能找到我们的工作。我们发现培养好奇心与各种社会情感技能、幸福感、学术参与度以及共同的人性意识有关。它改善了与那些与你不同的人的联系感。所以人际好奇心，我们现在正在创建一个名为“社会健康研究所”的整个机构，它将围绕这个框架和方法培训人们，我们想推广它。这是一个虚拟研究所。在世界各地，因为我们有太多的教育工作者、家长和孩子想要接受这种方法和框架的培训。所以我们正在建立它。我想说的最后一件事是，我们正在
building a Center for Youth and Connection by Design Technology because I'm determined to introduce the concept of connection by design technology. Technology is not the problem. I want to tell you all parents that are listening. It's the way we've designed technology that's so toxic so that friendship becomes how many likes I get or whether I have influencers or followers. We can create a technology that actually fosters our natural interpersonal curiosity that actually is what we're calling connection by design technology that fosters human to human connection. We can even use AI to foster human to human connection if we want to. And we're building it with an app we're building now called Agapi that we've been working with teenagers for the last year every week to co-design it.
建立一个“青年与设计技术联系中心”，因为我决心引入“设计技术联系”的概念。技术不是问题所在。我想告诉所有正在收听的家长。是我们设计技术的方式太有毒了，以至于友谊变成了我获得了多少个赞，或者我是否有网红或粉丝。我们可以创造一种真正培养我们天生人际好奇心的技术，这实际上就是我们所说的“设计技术联系”，它促进人与人之间的联系。如果我们愿意，我们甚至可以使用人工智能来促进人与人之间的联系。我们正在用一个名为Agapi的应用程序来构建它，我们过去一年每周都与青少年合作进行共同设计。
We're coming out with an MVP of the app in August that basically nurtures friendships and bridges divides by using my practices of listening with curiosity and we gamify it. So it begins fun and engaging and kids get listening points and all sorts of things. But it's a fun thing to do. But kids have teenagers have helped us create it. So made sure it stays fun. But the point is we need to create a pro-social culture. And there's lots of ways of doing it in your homes, in your schools, through technology, right? We just need to recognize the problem, Kim, is an antisocial culture. and thus the solution, right, is a pro-social culture. If we're social by nature, which we are, then our antisocial culture, it's a culture-nature-clash.
我们将在八月份推出该应用程序的MVP，它基本上通过使用我“带着好奇心倾听”的实践来培养友谊并弥合分歧，我们将它游戏化了。所以它开始变得有趣和引人入胜，孩子们获得倾听积分和各种各样的东西。但这是一件有趣的事情。但是孩子们，青少年们帮助我们创造了它。所以确保它保持有趣。但重点是我们必须创造一种亲社会文化。在你的家里、学校里、通过技术，有很多方法可以做到这一点，对吧？我们只需要认识到问题，Kim，是一种反社会文化。因此，解决方案，对吧，是一种亲社会文化。如果我们天生是社会性的，我们确实是，那么我们的反社会文化就是一种文化与本性的冲突。
And the solution is to create a pro-social culture so that aligns better with our social nature. Well, Dr. Way, this has been really interesting. I think your work is quite important. And I'm going to stay tuned to see what comes next. Thank you for joining me. Yeah, thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website. at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
解决方案是创造一种亲社会文化，使其更好地与我们的社会本性保持一致。好吧，Way博士，这真的很有趣。我认为你的工作非常重要。我会持续关注接下来会发生什么。感谢你加入我。是的，非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集，网址是speakingofpsychology.org，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由Lee Wynerman制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是Kim Mills。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。